Speaker 1: But there's also plenty of room, by the
way, for hate, good old fashioned bigotry as well.
And you want to find it. You need look no further,
of course, than the modern Republican Party. This
week, Republican Senator Roger Marshall from the
state of Kansas announced that he's contemplating
blocking an effort. A bipartisan effort in the
Senate. To fund a school lunch programs across
the United States because he's worried the Biden
administration might use this as an opportunity
to not let states discriminate against
LGBTQ youth. Let me read his statement
as to why he's currently on the fence. About
feeding kids lunches at school. Here he is.
I'm just afraid that schools in Kansas won't have
school lunches because of this administration's
radical view on transgender issues. And I'm
afraid that they're going to raid the school
lunch program over that issue. Now seems a little
confusing. I understand. Here is what this idiot
is. Confusing. Mr. Marshall. Senator Marshall,
I'll give them that title. Senator Marshall
believes that the USDA's guidance on who
can receive funding, which is, of course,
you got to make sure you do not allow
discrimination and bullying of LGBTQ youth
in your school. If you do that, if we find out you
were in violation, we will take away your money,
the USDA says, but only if you are receiving
federal money for nutritional programs.
It does not apply to the school lunch program.
So Senator Marshall isn't even talking about the
right thing. But it doesn't matter, right? He
didn't take the 5 seconds that it would take to
understand that he is confused. Two completely
separate issues. All he knows. Is, Hey, schools
in Kansas may be bullying LGBTQ kids and we don't
want to lose our lunches, so nobody gets a lunch.
You're going to tank this whole effort,
a bipartisan effort, by the way,
that they're trying to ram through quickly, which
is why you only need one objection to stall it.
They're trying to ram it through before June 30th
when the funding for the current program expires.
So Senator Marshall, I guess, would
rather see all kids go hungry.
Then have to see school districts not
allow LGBTQ youth to be bullied in school.
Right. Let's just make everybody go hungry.
Because we want to see kids get bullied. And
again, it's all actually because he doesn't even
understand that he is confused. Two completely
separate issues. Hmm. What a party, right?
Listen, we got to take another quick
break, but if you want even more from me,
follow me across social media, Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram at fair and balanced. And you can find
me on my YouTube channels at YouTube.com, slash
the Ring of Fire, YouTube.com, slash fair and
balanced. I'm also the host of the weekly
Ring of Fire podcast, which you can find
online at RDF podcast dot com. This is The David
Pakman Show. And we'll be right back with more.